unchosen suffering is going to happen in
life your parents are going to pass away
loved ones are going to die your
relationships are going to break down
your body is going to fail you you're
going to become ill or sick or destitute
things are going to happen do you think
you have no control over and the only
way that you can prepare yourself for
unchosen suffering is with chosen
suffering you can elect to put yourself
into a position to become a stronger
Ally of whatever the metal is that
you're made of and by purposefully
choosing difficult things you will armor
yourself against that situation it's
still gonna suck but think about how
much more fragile you would be if you
hadn't overcome all of this stuff every
single person that I know that is
incredibly successful in a balanced way
and has a good perspective on it elects
to do very hard things regularly